the disney holiday sing-along took place
last night with bts
getting they doing a holiday classic and
carrie washington surprising
a lot of people as she showed off her
own pipes on a christmas stand
[Music]
and yeah it was a family affair for pink
as she sang with her nine-year-old
daughter
willow and michael buble gathered his
kids
around the christmas tree it's beginning
to look a lot
like christmas
everywhere you go
take a look at the five and ten it's
glistening once again
handy canes and silver lanes the globe
and so i'm offering this simple phrase
to kids from 1 to 92.
although it's been said many times many
ways merry christmas
to you
[Applause]
and wonders of his love
of his love
[Music]
merry christmas everybody
i mean there's a lot in there some
people are commenting right away about
willow pink's daughter
nelson jazzy and mommy says yeah mommy
says the kid inherited the chords like
she just not just
consistently singing she has a great
voice so she's only nine years old yeah
what'd you think about kerry washington
keisha
do i do i have to i'd like to
[Laughter]
cool carrie she's such a great actor
though i will say that
but i also do wonder why did kerry
washington do that i think i mean she's
not
the greatest thing in the world but she
was very very solid like i don't really
get why carrie
put herself through that like there was
no reason to do that she's not promoting
anything i know she's
i think she's singing in the prom the
netflix movie coming up this is abc so
it's not like right
she's promoting that so i don't really
know why carrie decided you know what
i'm gonna go see joy to the world on
this thing
like good for her for doing it but i
just don't really know why no and i
could i could see if it was a mix of
sort of celebrity non-singers with you
know pro singers
but it wasn't that no it was just her so
i don't know what
like good on her she wanted to end up
for 2020. yeah enjoyed the world for
millions of people but
that's a tough crowd to stick yourself
in the middle of too yeah
tough crowd it's a tough crowd that
indeed
indeed can i just say she is a queen an
incredible actress literally the best
she's so dope oh the bts yeah this bts
doing santa claus by the time that was
what do you think what did you think of
bts keisha
i have the r i shout out to the army
[Music]
you two are so scared saying yeah just
as kerry washington sings yeah
apparently she does
mommy says miss olivia pope and
christmas it was fun it was good to see
them all together nice to see buble
just last thing i mean what the buble
family has been through over the past
oh yeah just sitting around the
christmas tree
having some fun and someone said it's
time for uh
buble to come out of his cave it's
christmas time i mean we've all been in
caves in 2020 so yes
yeah yeah we need because buble is
christmas
buble is christmas but can i just say on
a side note the production value of this
entire thing
and you know like for bts fans carrie
fans pink fans i mean michael
this is very exciting for them
especially during the holidays like
we've had a tough year so it's nice to
see your favorite artists your favorite
celebrities actors and whatnot
doing something special for the holidays
and at a such high production value
this is not a zoom video people this is
a lot of iphone video okay this is high
quality production
yeah i wonder what the pink one because
it was outside like because pink has a
big property i can't remember where she
lives
but you wonder like does disney just
send you all that stuff like it's
not the tree so that that is backdrop it
would not surprise me at all
yeah the ratings were huge for this like
you had like six million people watching
so like you said kisha
people want this stuff this time of year
so yeah it's great to see you and
anytime you do anything like this where
you get you know where andrea bocelli is
a part of it
it's like it's you have to watch because
you're going to cry right you're going
to get goosebumps you're going to see
some stuff you've never seen before
and andrea buchelli's going to make you
cry and that's exactly what it was but
the production value was nuts that katy
perry thing which he was in dressed up
as a christmas tree was
incredible it was like i loved it i
loved all of it now you mentioned andre
patel again it's like yeah kerry
washington was in there too yeah
carrie washington and andrea buchelli
you know and anyone what more do you
want
on any singing show where you can tune
in and see andrea pacelli and kerry
washington yeah really what more could
you ask for